Let's go to our next call. Caller from the
six to six area code. Who's calling today
from six to six.
Hello, David, this is Ramon. Hey Ramon. Okay.
So I have a question regarding, um, Trump's
support. You coming for the, um, 20, 20 election.
I know that he has a strong base and they
are very much very committed to him. I would
say drinking the orange, believe the Kuwait.
Yes, but um, check this out though. I saw
an article, um, very recently that, uh, with
uh, Trump how he is, um, with his, uh, lack
of morality advocacy and how he's handling,
you know, recent events such as mass shootings,
a lack of gun control and the tariff war with
China. Um, I read that he could be losing
some kind of support, um, whether it's someone
from people from those who vote for him back
in 2016 and thought that, um, he's not doing
much of a good job or those who voted for
him who have a moral standards and to feel
that he used to not win the up to that kind
of morality or independence as a whole, who
I believe that he really needs to be reelected,
especially in the rust belt states. So I want
to know if you have any kind of, um, if you
seen somebody like that or what your take,
is it about his support coming in for 2020.
I mean, listen, so what you're, you're saying
something that's qualitative, which I appreciate,
which is there are farmers who are realizing
that Trump's tariffs are crushing them. We
played a clip earlier this week of a mom and
daughter who vote in and they're Republicans,
but they can't vote for Trump because they
think he's crazy on immigration. Like qualitatively.
Yeah. That there are people who are Republicans
and voted Trump in 2016 who are not going
to vote, vote Trump in 2020 the thing is,
it's like, so what in the sense of that, there's
no strategy around that. Right? If people
are on the right and they've decided I can't
vote for Trump again, then that's great. They're,
they're not voting for Trump. They're already
sort of out of the equation. Then it's just
a matter of what is it that the Democratic
Party and eventual candidate can do to defeat
Trump and get people to vote.
Find people who already agree with you but
might not be planning to vote and get them
to vote. So I don't know what the numbers
are of what you're talking about. There are
Trumpists from 2016 who won't be voting Trump
in 2020. There are probably some people who
didn't even vote at all in 2016 who now loved
Trump and are going to vote. I just think
that it's a non factor in terms of strategy
because the strategy never was to convince
Trump voters to change their minds. It's some
of them will, some won't. We've got to get
our base out, if that makes sense.
Yeah. And that leads me to my next question
just regarding former governor, former representative
Mark Sanford, who, um, he had expressed interest
in running for president against Trump and
the GOP primary. Now I don't know if he's
going to run as a GOP for the GOP ticket or
I don't know if he's gonna run as a third
party PR as a third party. But, um, if you
can recall back in 1992, would Ross Perot,
the late Ross Perot, now he ran it as a third
party and it hurt, um, George h w Bush during
the reelection. Do you think that may have,
uh, the same effect or very similar effect?
If he did. So,
I don't know that Sanford specifically is
the guy to have that effect. But yeah, I mean,
mathematically I would love a strong, a primary
challenge to Trump because it would just delay
the amount of time it would delay when he
can really start focusing on running the general
if he's running a primary. So I would love
that if someone runs third party and can actually
get to 3% of the vote that would pull republican
votes, that would be absolutely fantastic.
And it could literally be the difference maker
and defeating Trump in 2020 so I'm for all
of that stuff, as long as you know, I'm not
going to support someone where it's less clear
who they're taking votes from. Like the Howard
Schultz thing, there was disagreement over
who would Howard Schultz have taken more votes
from the Democratic nominee or Trump, different
people at different ideas. If there's a republican
running third party who clearly will hurt
Trump, I'm all for that 100%
all right. Now, one quick question. This very
quick. Okay. I'm not yet a member, but yeah,
I have your personal authorization person's
permission to become a member of the Dina
package show.
Yup. Oh, you're completely, you, you, I've
authorized you fully two by a hundred memberships
for yourself.
Yeah. I just hope, yeah, to have you on the
line of is we'll ask you
good. Yep. No, I'm completely forward that
and I look forward to welcoming you as a member.
Good. I do that too.
All right. Okay. Thanks. I appreciate the
phone call. Great to hear from you.